[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález en el año 2017
el portal de noticias armando info dio a
conocer un nombre hasta ese momento
desconocido
álex saab un hombre que cobraría
muchísima relevancia con el paso de los
años y gracias también a los datos
revelados por esta investigación
periodística que se sumaron a las
investigaciones del departamento de
justicia y del departamento del tesoro
de eeuu años después en
2021 la justicia de eeuu recibió en
extradición al empresario y diplomático
alexa up quien es acusado por cargos de
lavado de activo y también de blanqueo
de capitales es considerado un personaje
clave en el gobierno de venezuela por
haber participado en varios de los
programas bandera del chavismo y por ser
una conexión internacional en términos
de negocios para el palacio de
miraflores
saab compareció este lunes ante un juez
del tribunal del distrito federal
el distrito del sur de florida en eeuu
en la que sería su primera audiencia
formada tras su extradición desde el
archipiélago de cabo verde
su captura preocupa muchísimo a nicolás
maduro y a su gobierno por lo que esa
pueda llegar a decir escuchemos
el gobierno de eeuu y aseguró a la
plataforma unitaria que no se iba a
llevar a álex at porque iba a romper con
el diálogo y lo hizo no soy escaparate
de nadie lo hizo con alevosía con
espíritu criminal
secuestró alexa
los secuestros y nosotros en protesta
nos fuimos de mexico y punto después
evaluaremos qué va a pasar con esos
diálogos después de valores por ahora
estamos indignados y protestando y
enfrentando la injusticia después
veremos
muchos creen que sus declaraciones
hablando de las declaraciones de saab
pueden hacer tambalear al gobierno de
nicolás maduro otros creen que no va a
suceder absolutamente nada más allá de
un despliegue mediático y la furia de
caracas contra washington
el régimen de maduro en cambio ha dejado
muy claro que está poniendo sus
intereses una vez más por encima del
interés del pueblo venezolano quien se
lo están poniendo el caso de un
individuo por encima del bienestar por
encima del sustento de millones de
venezolanos lo va a hacer bueno la
pregunta acá o las preguntas acá que
tanto sabe alexa up que tan importante
puede ser su testimonio que tanto afecta
esto en las relaciones entre eeuu y
venezuela que en movimiento podría ser
la oposición venezolana aprovechando
este remezón qué va a ser nicolás maduro
hoy en el debate de france 24 hablar a
alexa para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a pasiano padrón el ex
presidente de bnamericas y también
docente de urbe university él es
venezolano se encuentra en la ciudad de
miami también está con nosotros roberto
denis él es periodista de investigación
en armando info precisamente el medio de
comunicación que dio a conocer quién era
alexa up y su importancia para el
gobierno de venezuela en sus negocios
internacionales y aquí en el estudio de
france 24 está con nosotros alejandro
cardoso uscátegui él es doctor en
historia politólogo y también profesor
de ciencias políticas y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad sergio
arboleda de la ciudad de bogotá france24
también intentó convocar para este
debate a alguien cercano al gobierno de
nicolás maduro para conocer sus puntos
de vista sobre este tema pero no fue
posible tener a un invitado para este
programa y tampoco una declaración
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en facebook
en instagram bien twitter síganos como
france24
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios
participen dejen sus preguntas sus
comentarios a lo largo del programa pues
ya tenemos a los invitados tenemos el
contexto vamos a empezar el análisis con
nuestros invitados comienzo aquí en el
estudio de france 24 con alejandro
cardoso alejandro bienvenido gracias por
acompañarnos y qué es lo que sabe a
alexa a que nicolás maduro teme y su
gobierno se estremece con esta con este
enviado de extradición desde cabo verde
hasta los eeuu gracias santiago bueno la
propiedad fiscal luisa ortega como todos
sabemos pues lo ha lo ha señalado como
el testaferro de maduro cargo súper
pesado no éste debe saber mucho porque
hasta crispó el gobierno de putin hasta
rusia inclusive hace un par de semanas
expuso como una situación sine quanon el
hecho de que saab fuera liberado para
que las mesas de diálogo de méxico
continuarán
en
la mesa de diálogo en méxico en los
asuntos latinoamericanos etcétera muy
fuerte de una potencia euroasiática
entonces yo creo que sabe bastante si va
a pasar a conectar con nuestro invitado
en la ciudad de miami pacianopadron
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en el
debate de france 24 sigamos conformando
este rompecabezas con diferentes piezas
yo daba algunas luces algunos indicios
de la importancia que puede tener alexa
para el gobierno de nicolás maduro que
más se sabe de él que más accesos tenía
alexa para el interior del gobierno de
nicolás maduro
gracias santiago por lo pronto sabemos
que es ni empresario ni diplomático cómo
se representa esto es un delincuente
farsante que por lo demás sabe muchísimo
cansaba muchísimo que está absolutamente
no indignado sino asustado escuchábamos
ahorita al señor maduro es el rostro no
era de una persona indignada en un
hombre asustado temerosos con muchísimo
miedo porque alexa ciertamente que es su
hombre de confianza su testaferro es
probablemente la persona que obtuvo el
mayor número de contratos a lo largo de
la gestión de los últimos años vivienda
gimnasio y contratos de pereza logró una
licitación por encima de todas las
empresas en una empresa absolutamente
desconocido inspira está por supuesto a
la compra de alimentos pero más allá de
esto es ciertamente quien ha venido
guardando el dinero del de maduro y el
dinero de la familia
de maduro por eso entonces su actuación
lo hace venezolano a quien es un
colombiano barranquillero por supuesto
mal mal nacionalizado sin sin el
procedimiento simplemente se le ocurre
decir es venezolano lo convirtieron en
diplomático lo hizo un negociador lo
colocó en la mesa de negociación qué
mérito qué conocimiento pudiera tener
simplemente tratando de salvarlo
tratando de impedir y gato 270 millones
para lograr mantenerlo 490 días en cabo
verde que no viniera a los estados
unidos median aquí estamos muy contentos
llegada sin proveer todo de nicéforo de
los periodistas que dio a conocer a
través de su investigación quién era
álex sáb roberto le pregunto hagamos un
poco retrospectiva cómo llega a alexa up
a venezuela y cómo llega a él a moverse
en las altas esferas del gobierno de
venezuela y del chavismo como logra
llegar a tener tanta confianza de
personajes clave de la política
venezolana y de nicolás maduro
hay varias etapas de alexa ahora
obviamente está digamos en el en el
centro de todas las noticias pero a
veces se pierde la perspectiva alexa
llega venezuela desde el año 2011 ahí
obtiene el primer gran contrato que era
un esquema para un negocio para la
construcción de viviendas prefabricadas
esto es un contrato de cientos de
millones de dólares se le otorga estaba
vivo todavía el presidente chávez
es un negocio que por cierto fue
investigado durante mucho tiempo por la
fiscalía general de ecuador porque se
sospechaba de operaciones de lavado de
dinero y ecuador- por la razón de que
ellos escogieron y digo ellos álex up y
sus socios escogieron
ecuador como país desde dejara despachar
supuestamente los insumos más para la
construcción de esta vivienda pero hay
un punto aquí clave que es cuando maduro
asume la presidencia en abril de 2013
que el digamos deja de ser un simple
contratista para convertirse en el gran
contratista ya alexa para ese momento
había logrado una cercanía con el
entorno familiar del nicolás maduro
álex había llegado a venezuela de la
mano de la ex senadora colombiana piedad
córdoba quien es amiga de alexa así lo
han manifestado y lo han reconocido
mutuamente y como digo ya con maduro
digamos desde miraflores empiezan a caer
negocios de toda índole de construcción
de obras públicas acceso a divisas
preferenciales cuando estaba digamos
vigente el control de cambio
un contrato millonario con una empresa
fantasmal petrolera llamada tren a co
tan fantasma el que al final ese
contrato se cae porque pedevesa se da
cuenta de que era un error es un
contrato algo así de como de cuatro mil
millones de dólares para la explotación
de la faja petrolífera del orinoco
después vino vino el programa de los
claves que nosotros publicamos y
revelamos en 2017 por cierto al examen y
gavà estar detrás de los claro pero
ahora es el argumento principal querer
que esgrime intentando digamos buscar
una defensa que es decir que era una
especie de agente humanitario que
compraba alimentos claros y ya en los
últimos años hay un álex up que se
convierte como en una especie de bisagra
en una especie de emisor del propio
nicolás maduro para cerrar negocios y
hacer operaciones completamente opacas
de las que nunca se rindieron cuentas
con socios como turquía rusia y más
recientemente irán no es casualidad que
cuando álex up es detenido el 12 de
junio del 20 2 mil 20 en cabo verde eran
porque estaba haciendo una escala una
parada para seguir a irán
roberto usted perdona pasean o usted
mencionaba
la cara de nicolás maduro en la
declaración que citamos anteriormente al
inicio del programa y mencionaba a un
nicolás maduro
con miedo como si fuera como si
estuviera teniendo algo a quien le teme
nicolás maduro y que tanto puede revelar
entonces alexa up que es lo que hay allí
bajo de cuerda lo sabes roberto de ti
que además de un gran gran investigador
y a quien hemos seguido desde hace
muchos años me estén está
revelando los distintos elementos que ha
conseguido el señor sab ese hombre de
confianza mantiene el dinero de nicolás
maduro y es su testaferro y ha hecho
inversiones entonces en el mundo entero
que comienzan ya a conocerse buena parte
de ese dinero además va a poder ser
recuperado por el estado venezolano ya
de hecho hay cosas que han estado
cayendo 350 millones acá en los eeuu
ayer un millón punto ocho millones de
dólares de euros le quitaron a la señora
camila fabri allá en españa comienzan a
darse pasos en el propio colombia hay
unos 78 bienes que le acaban de quitar
en en barranquilla por 35 mil millones
de pesos colombianos es decir comienza
ya a salir y parte de esos bienes son de
nicolás maduro y de su familia pero
además se van a salir los nombres van a
salir las negociaciones se va a poner al
desnudo la situación y evidentemente
esto no le hace bien absolutamente a
nadie son de tabla tienen cara de tabla
y van a pretender el surfear sobre la
situación y de hecho tienen su propia
narrativa ya por ejemplo este es este
señor que es un delincuente para maduro
lo presenta como nuestro héroe y
diplomático figúrate tú
aquí en el estudio de france 24
alejandro esto tal parece que es una red
que tiene tentáculos no solamente al
interior de venezuela del interior del
gobierno a nicolás maduro lo citaba pas
ya no hay activos y propiedades en
colombia en eeuu varias cuentas también
hay varias cosas en españa en otros
países de europa
si esto empieza a moverse estamos ante
un gigantesco caso de una red de
y corrupción a nivel internacional
dirigido desde caracas como lo ve usted
evidentemente puede ser el gran
escándalo de corrupción del siglo 21
pero y del siglo 20 pero aparte de eso
aparte no unido lo que dices yo pienso
que la diplomacia de maduro la paria
diplomacia de maduro burguesa una
diplomacia de parias consta como de
digamos
archipiélagos la diplomacia y maduro son
archipiélagos y saab se volvió
súbitamente un dispositivo para activar
parte de esa diplomacia vital si en la
misma fuerza en que se volvió vital como
dispositivo activar esa paria diplomacia
en los diferentes archipiélagos me
refiero archipiélagos que irán rusia
turquía zonas
muy de muy alejadas del caribe y de
américa latina cuba nicaragua es decir
son archipiélagos los que cuentan con
los que cuenta maduro tal vez el más
legítimo de su archipiélago ahora mismo
sea méxico pero en ese sentido álex up
ahora se una contra fuerza un
dispositivo que vaya en contra de la
diplomacia de maduro porque está de mano
de eeuu y eso va a reventar varios
puentes ya que hace que hay un puente
ese archipiélago con las declaraciones
de una política acá que
pues dice que el presidente el ex
presidente español tiene ostenta minas
en venezuela entonces estamos viendo
cómo son a caer ciertos puentes tu
archipiélago
como usted de roberto sobre la ola de
tsunami que puede generar esto o el
efecto dominó que pueda tener esto a
nivel internacional
lo menciona alejandro varios países
implicados venezuela ha negociado ha
hecho intercambios de oro a cambio de
comida de armas de mantener protección a
nivel internacional esto va a generar
una ola de tsunami a nivel mundial
yo siempre digo para que quien no está
familiarizado con el caso alex up se
haga una dimensión que alexa en sí mismo
es una especie de caso odebrecht
recordarán el caso odebrecht empieza en
brasil pero de ahí se expande y afecta a
círculos políticos empresariales de toda
américa latina por decir lo menos con
alexa vamos a ver algo similar
evidentemente hay una toda unas
repercusiones y unas y unas
vinculaciones innegables con venezuela
hemos visto todo lo que se ha dicho y
todo lo que se ha hecho para evitar su
extradición a los estados unidos por
cierto algún paréntesis el señor alega
enseñando con las maduro nunca se había
referido nunca había pronunciado en
público el nombre alexa hasta hace como
tres semanas cuando decidieron sumar los
supuestamente a la mesa negociación en
mexico pero álex up también conecta con
políticos empresarios de colombia alexa
por ejemplo entre 2014 y 2019 tuvo una
especie de pasaporte diplomático de
antigua y barbuda porque porque será una
jurisdicción que usaba para mover el
dinero que recibía de contratos
venezuela a bancos de la isla imagino
que por eso le dan el pasaporte yo
supongo que os el primer ministro de ese
país aún sigue siéndolo gastón brown
deberá decir o explicar por qué le dio
ese
pasaporte a este señor hay
investigaciones en marcha que yo tenga
conocimiento en el principado de
liechtenstein porque por allá también se
ha movido dinero en otros países de
europa en noviembre de 2019 la guardia
de finanza italiana
actuó contra la esposa de álex a camila
favre y familiares de ella porque
sospechaba que se estaban usando digamos
a estas personas para justamente lavar
dinero procedente a los negocios de
alexa y como decía antes más
recientemente todas las operaciones
opacas que se están haciendo con rusia
con turquía por ejemplo turquía turquía
el señor alex a diego toneladas de oro
venezolano nicolás maduro le delegó casi
que la exportación de oro venezolano
tanto de las reservas del banco central
de venezuela como el oro extraído de las
minas al sur del país y los venezolano
con la opinión pública no tenemos la
mayor información de qué se hizo con ese
oro a dónde fue a parar a cambio de que
se entregó ese oro y finalmente irán así
así pues que sin lugar a dudas yo creo
que aquí va unas repercusiones
gigantescas soy pesimista lo que pueda
pasar a lo interno venezuela porque
lamentablemente
venezolano tiene un sistema judicial
independiente es probablemente el primer
fiscal que debió moverse investigar
estos el fiscal venezolano y más bien lo
que ha salido es a repetir el discurso
de nicolás maduro diciendo que es un
diplomático pero creo que en otros
países vamos a ver
un importante digamos unas importantes
dimensiones y conexiones con alexa
paseando en la ciudad de miami ahora que
alexa app se encuentra en la ciudad de
miami allí en el estado de la florida
está tal vez la casa blanca tensando
mucho la relación con caracas la
relación con venezuela en un momento en
el que estaba avanzando un diálogo
aparentemente a un ritmo
que la gente estaba viendo algunos
acuerdos o por lo menos una mesa de
diálogo en marcha entre la oposición y
el gobierno de nicolás maduro está
tensando mucho la relación casablanca
miraflores
es una relación que en este momento
pareciera no estar planteada en serio ni
la negociación que se realiza en méxico
tiene nada que ver con esto la
negociación en méxico ha sido un empeño
de la comunidad internacional que
agradecemos con el inter con el interés
que se pongan de acuerdo a las partes en
una fecha y en unas elecciones libres
abiertas verificables para tener un
nuevo presidente y nuevo parlamento eso
no le interesa a maduro esa es
negociación no se va a dar esa mesa está
condenada al fracaso lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es intentar cerrarla
lo más pronto posible más madura un
interés un pepino y la mejor
demostración de ello es haber colocado a
alexa en la mesa para protegerlo y
retirarse ahora de la mesa porque sab
fue fue extraditado maduro si está
ciertamente muy preocupado el santiago
por la situación porque no es solamente
esa ahora es claudia patricia del día la
ex enfermera y ex tesorera que va a ser
extraditadas también a los eeuu es el
pollo carvajal que está diciendo cosas
tan importantes que han llevado
solamente a que se sepa lo de la mina de
este el ex presidente zapatero es lo que
han tenido que reabrir el caso de
podemos el financiamiento del partido
podemos y el juez garcía castellón
reabre este expediente a partir de la
información que se están dando son
muchas cosas las que vienen el fiscal
carl icahn de la cpi estará en colombia
en estos próximos días y para pasar a
venezuela por cierto él estamos
solicitando desde si si venden el comité
internacional contra la impunidad
venezuela que reciba a las víctimas
venezolanas tanto en colombia como en su
visita a venezuela eso sí le preocupa yo
creo que no está durmiendo bien en estos
días
alejandra aquí en el estudio france24
viendo tantas personas de poder
involucradas en este caso aparentemente
esto toca ya lo decían ustedes altas
esferas políticas empresarios se puede
confiar en el sistema internacional para
que esto llegue a un puerto concreto se
puede confiar en la institucionalidad
a nivel internacional para llegar a un
fin en este caso o la corrupción allí al
alto nivel podría salir a relucir
tremenda pregunta
yo creo que el sistema internacional
tiene una capacidad de respuesta
más lenta de la capacidad de estas redes
tejerse y a activarse yo pienso que la
lista clinton los listos fuck y creo que
todas estas cúpulas le temen muchísimo
más a la lista ofac que a la gobernanza
global es decir el sistema internacional
se ha puesto a prueba chávez lo empezó a
poner a prueba y
siempre se salió bien su primer viaje a
bagdad primer presidente que visita en
ese momento al paria número uno del
mundo que era san josé es decir el el
madrid el chavismo del madridismo han
puesto a prueba el sistema internacional
y siempre ha salido bien pero yo creo
que aquí lo determinante va a ser la
lista clinton la lista ofac y mucha
gente para lavarse la cara ante la lista
fuck va a tumbar los puentes que éste
decía hace 7 minutos los pueden tener el
archipiélago diplomático de maduro yo
creo que ese va a ser el efecto
evidente o más esperado hago la ronda a
la inversa paciano de la ciudad de miami
esos puentes que menciona alejandro
podríamos ver a presidentes como por
ejemplo recep tayib erdogán en turquía
lavándose las manos dándole la espalda a
venezuela o al presidente putin también
tratando de salvarse en este tipo de
escenarios internacionales usted cómo lo
ve
santiago lópez cuando comienza a la
candela a arder las ratas salen
corriendo y tratan de por supuesto
encontrarse a salvo qué va a pasar acá
no lo sabemos hasta dónde va a hablar
sabe cuántas cosas se van a colocar
sobre la mesa cuántos implicado
venezolanos y no venezolanos hay hay en
estos mira esto esto es fuerte grave y
seguramente que va a poner a correr a
más de uno este señor rap es ciertamente
un delincuente con un vuelo al cual se
le dio porque tenía todo el poder del
estado todo el respaldo de son nicolás
maduro lo cual hace que en definitiva
haya hecho cosas que otros no hicieron
nunca
roberto y esta misma pregunta pero a
escala de venezuela al interior del país
usted ya mencionaba no se puede creer en
la institucionalidad y en la justicia
venezolana que no ha actuado en este más
hasta el momento no ha hecho
absolutamente nada en ningún tipo de
acusación frente a este caso como lo
podemos ver a nivel nacional esto
generará rupturas fragmentación en un
punto de quiebre qué repercusión trae
esto para el interior de venezuela para
los venezolanos que están allí
creo que ahí tenemos que entrar un poco
en el terreno de la especulación pero lo
que sí está muy claro es que hasta ahora
es muy fácil ver quiénes son los que
están más preocupados digamos en lo alto
del poder político en venezuela por el
caso el caso alexa pongo un ejemplo ayer
diosdado cabello por muchos considerado
como el número 2 del chavismo durante
mucho tiempo
apenas colocó un tweet digamos
refiriéndose para referirse al caso y
condenar la tradición pero digamos no se
ha involucrado en esta campaña y en
todas en todas estas dependa que se ha
hecho durante un año yo sí creo que
puede generar cierto malestar a lo
interno de esas estructuras de poder que
hay el chavismo recordemos que al final
aunque parece que maduro tiene un poder
digamos consolidado al final estos
grupos de poder está muy fragmentado por
un lado están los hermanos rodríguez
está el grupo de los militares diosdado
cabello está el entorno de nicolás
maduro
y que se haya puesto tanto esfuerzo que
se está haciendo todo lo que se está
haciendo que se haya llegado el punto de
levantar la mesa de negociación en
méxico por alec sabes decir todo por
alexa yo creo que a lo interno del
maderismo y del chavismo debe debe
generar digamos algunas fricciones
alguna roces han pasado otros casos el
doctor pas ya no mencionaba en este
mismo momento el caso de la posible
extradición de claudia díaz es la ex
tesorera en la nación y la posible
tradición del pollo carvajal porque a
estos señores no se los defiende tan
apasionadamente como se está defendiendo
al ex up y yo creo que cuando tengamos
esa respuesta es que nos vamos a dar
cuenta de la gravedad que hay detrás de
todo esto en ese orden de ideas y
hablando de esa defensa nicolás maduro
decía que iba a llevar este caso hasta
las altas instituciones a nivel
internacional a organismos
internacionales como la onu en fin a
todas las instancias posibles para
defender a este diplomático como lo
califica caracas así lo califica nicolás
maduro cuáles pueden ser entonces las
repercusiones que pueda tener esto la
represalia el mejor que pueda tener esto
desde nicolás maduro que cuál puede ser
la reacción desde caracas hacia no
y algunas cosas ha hecho como esto de
separarse de la mesa del equipo y
declarar toda una semana de alexa que se
está que se comenzó en el día de ayer
lunes y está intentando por supuesto
defender hasta donde pueda y darle que
yo creo que es fuerza a saab para que no
hable su inmensa preocupación ahorita es
que sabe se destape que ésta comience a
decir porque ya por supuesto muchos
bienes van a hacer van a ser expropiados
les van a ser quitados que van a ser
devueltos al tesoro nacional venezolano
en su momento pero es uno eso para él no
es lo que más le preocupa es lo que le
preocupa es que pueda sal puedan salir
los nombres y los bienes que están a su
nombre evidentemente puedan perderse y
los viernes de su familia porque es
realmente increíble la cantidad de
dinero que este hombre logró manejar
logró acumular de manera absolutamente
indebida bueno ya hago la misma pregunta
que en el estudio alejandro represalias
que pueda tomar maduro frente a este
caso porque dijo que estaba dispuesto
prácticamente a todo hablar de
organismos internacionales cuando él
mismo creó el sistema internacional sí
porque él es un padre del sistema
entonces no veo qué más puede hacer
aunque los parias son los que más cuidan
la forma de sistema internacional porque
el sistema intencional termina
defendiendo los paradójicamente no esté
pero puedo decirte algo la arquitectura
de esa diplomacia es obra de chávez pero
quien la termina usufructuando realmente
es maduro no con estos esquemas con euro
asia etcétera con nicaragua
y áfrica también está muy muy presente
pero lo que me parece con el caso de
saab es una falta tremenda de
creatividad por haber puesto todos los
juegos una sola canasta a veces nombrado
un solo plenipotenciario operador porque
lo que es es un gran operador luego lo
nombran plenipotenciario en la
diplomacia pero es un plenipotenciario
operador de presión a gran falta de
creatividad no entres architecture yo
creo que la represalia yo creo que va a
ser una
auto castigo por haber puesto todos los
huevos no son las canastas me parece
increíble esa falta de creatividad no
y precisamente en esa misma línea
roberto al interior del chavismo y bueno
el velma durísmo quién puede llegar a
suplir ese espacio que deja saab porque
necesariamente nicolás maduro
es indispensable para el tener a alguien
que pueda hacer estas negociaciones
internacionales que le pueda garantizar
ese oxígeno que mantiene todavía vivo a
maduro allí en el poder quien podría
llegar a ese vacío que queda
como explicaba antes digamos en lo más
alto del poder político en venezuela se
han establecido grupos y estos grupos a
su vez tienen sus grupos digamos de este
tipo de operadores financieros que se
encargan de negocios por cierto en
negocios en nombre de la crisis
humanitaria de venezuela que estos aquí
lolo parados y con ahora se usa la
crisis para justificar que supuestamente
había una especie de emisario
humanitario como el señor
alexa nosotros en armando puntoinfo
hemos documentado por ejemplo que
alrededor de los hermanos rodríguez hay
un grupo igual de poderoso que son los
abuná shift una gente de origen unos
venezolanos de origen libanés que están
al igual que álex adoptando cantidad de
negocios está el caso de sant marc lópez
quien era una ficha importantísima y
creo que lo sigue siendo en los negocios
y digamos en el grupo de tarek el
aissami
sanz marc lópez sí ya fue sancionado por
el departamento del tesoro hace un
tiempo fue incluido en la lista ofac
y aquí hay otro elemento es decir ha
pasado mucho tiempo desde la detención
de alexa
yo no tengo dudas que durante todo este
año se habrá hecho hasta lo imposible
por tratar de borrar ciertos rastros por
tratar de recuperar activos de la forma
digamos más más opaca posible entonces
yo creo que en ese sentido en
esta época digamos con maduro se ha
demostrado una enorme capacidad de
buscar este tipo de personaje para hacer
este tipo de negociados a las sombras
del país pero pero no cree usted que
vaya a haber una especie de pugna
interna o una disputa por por esto por
este control de de tener acceso a todas
las riquezas de venezuela para comerciar
al nivel internacional
yo creo que esa pugna es permanente y
diaria lo que pasa es que nunca nunca
digamos nunca la vemos necesariamente no
no la vemos en los titulares de prensa
pero pero ese reparto es más si uno ve
por ejemplo el negocio de los clark ese
del suministro de los alimentos que en
principio una persona desde desde otro
lugar pues una política razonable no
buscar alimentos y entregárselos a
precios de subsidiar los más pobres
bueno eso se convirtió en un reparto de
contratos a empresas fantasmas
registradas en hong kong panamá como las
que manejaba el señor alex a
contratos de cientos de millones de
dólares para que después alguien a
importar alimentos en el caso de los de
álex ar de la peor calidad posible y
llevarlas venezuela pero digamos alexa
fue el gran beneficiario pero detrás de
él en la cola digamos había varios
grupos de estos empresariales que
también llevaron su cuota de reparto en
este negocio sí ya vamos llegando al
final del programa para asia no quiero
preguntarle por el papel que pueda tener
aquí la oposición de venezuela pueden
aprovechar este remezón político en el
país para
y capitalizarlo alguna manera que piensa
usted
la posición el pueblo la sociedad civil
venezolana está llamada a actuar en esta
hora santiago es el momento es el tiempo
el maduro el tiempo está agotado ya ya
ya ya absolutamente nadie lo quiere ni
su propia gente basta ver esto que
estamos observando esa para entender
perfectamente cómo empobrecieron a
venezuela como se robaron al país siete
millones de los nuestros están en la
diáspora hoy eso significa un 25 por
ciento de la población una población
entre la más mísera en el mundo
entendiéndolo como el país 3 más pobre
con los indicadores más lamentable moco
eje es momento para el salir y yo tengo
fe en que va a ser así la gente va a
salir a la calle quiero cerrar el
programa con las conclusiones de lo que
cada uno de ustedes crea que va a
suceder en este caso lo que vaya a
suceder en eeuu en estas cortes y lo que
pueda suceder en caracas con nicolás
maduro comienzo aquí en el estudio con
alejandro rápidamente por favor la
conclusión sí bueno vuelvo sobre mis
ideas se van a quedar puentes dentro de
estos archipiélagos diplomáticos
básicamente y una cosa que hay que
rápidamente subrayar este este tipo de
tramas también parten de un hecho y por
tu pregunta de quién va a sustituir a
sap la empresa petrolera se desmoronó
entonces hay una desconcentración de la
renta la renta ahora viene del oro viene
de minas que es un control muy diferente
una empresa petrolera centralizada
unificada además milita por un
ministerio energía entonces bueno este
modo de corrupción es lo que vamos a ver
sustitutiva van a sustituirse con otros
personajes porque ya está
descentralizada si la operación
económica realizándose en cierta manera
roberto su conclusión 50 segundos
creo que es muy factible que en esta
encrucijada alexa termine negociando con
las autoridades de eeuu para conseguir
unos beneficios legales creo que hasta
ahora no hemos visto toda la película de
álex up creo que van a venir nuevos
nuevos capítulos y yo solo dejaría
abierto quizás un escenario estará
nicolás maduró dispuesto a negociar
directamente con los estados unidos por
la libertad de alexa pero podría ofrecer
nicolás maduró directamente con los eeuu
es un escenario posible también eso nos
queda para un siguiente capítulo paciano
su conclusión 30 segundos por favor para
terminar el programa
santiago todo es posible a partir del
momento en que se abra el juicio el
primero de noviembre una vez del 10
saldrá el nombre se satisfacer a así sea
parcialmente la sed de justicia del
pueblo venezolano se va a recuperar
buena parte del dinero y por supuesto se
van a caer mal el nombre la situación se
va a quedar perfectamente clara bueno
pues a pasearnos roberto de alejandro
muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y compartir sus puntos de vista
en torno a este tema ustedes muchas
gracias por participar a través de las
redes sociales sigan con la programación
de france 24
[Música]